Your heartbeat increases
Your pupils dilate to adjust to the dark
You see a staircase ahead of you
You run up the rest of the way not looking behind you you turn on the light and your heart on clenches
Fear is an interesting thing, isn't it?
So interesting that we at sites ago are here to give you five weird facts about being scared
One some people prefer the treat while others prefer the trick. That's right
Some people like being afraid they watch horror movies
They ride rollercoasters and they often take us along for the ride
but why do these people like being scared isn't fear and inherently a negative emotion when scared our
Instinctual survival response kicks into action this floods our body with hormones and neurotransmitters
Making us stronger and faster
Adrenaline is a hormone that plays a huge factor and gives us the rush some people crave
Fact number two. Most of our fears are nurture and not nature
we are born with two innate fears Heights and loud sounds
Most other fears are learned as children. We learn that snakes are scary based on the surrounding adult's reactions to snakes
3 the more scared you are the scarier things appear once scared
Your heartbeat is increased and you're on red alert for danger
This makes your body more jumpy than usual at least until the fight or flight response wears down
For fear guides decisions. Do you ever catch yourself going for the safe choice?
everyone does fear stops us from doing things we may want to do and
Funnily enough it also guides us into doing things
we don't want to do as a species were more scared of the stick than we want the carrot and
In a lot of cases the stick doesn't even exist
5 we can literally smell fear off of other humans we can tell when others are scared from what their sweat smells like
Although this is all unconscious. So you can exactly sniff your friends armpit during a scary movie
Even though we may not realize through our noses. Our brain can tell when specific fear chemicals are released from your pierce swept
Fear plays a huge part in our lives from roller coasters to skydiving do you like it?
Does it control you do you smell other people's armpits?
Please share with us in the comments below and finally, please don't smell other people's armpits
Don't forget to subscribe and let us know what video you want to see next. Thanks for watching